en la apertura del desfile anual ruso de
la victoria vladimir putin desarrolló su
punto de vista sobre la guerra en
ucrania
link grado nuestros soldados combatieron
al enemigo cerca de moscú y leningrado
jeff y minsk stalingrado y kursk
sebastopol y jarquín y ahora ustedes
luchan por nuestro pueblo en el donbass
por la seguridad de nuestra patria rusa
naciónel recibe
comparando su invasión con el momento en
que la unión soviética se enfrentó a la
alemania nazi durante la segunda guerra
mundial
putin señaló que occidente rechazó
cualquier diálogo constructivo previo a
la guerra
el presidente aseguró también que las
potencias occidentales quieren invadir
el territorio ruso y que no le dejan
otra alternativa a lo que llama
operación militar especial
una invernal de voz
se creó una amenaza absolutamente
inaceptable para nosotros y además justo
al lado de nuestras fronteras todo
indicaba que era inevitable un choque
con los neonazis los banderitas a los
que se jugaban eeuu y sus socios más
jóvenes repito vimos cómo se estaba
desarrollando la infraestructura militar
cómo comenzaron a trabajar cientos de
asesores extranjeros hubo entregas
regulares de las armas más modernas de
los países de la otan
el peligro crecía cada día rusia ha
rechazado preventivamente una agresión
fue una agresión forzada oportuna y la
única decisión correcta siendo la
supresión de visión para grecia
el silencio se apodera de la plaza roja
en honor a los soldados rusos caídos en
ucrania
no hay declaración formal de anexión de
la región del donbass controlada en gran
parte por moscú así como tampoco hay
declaración oficial de guerra a ucrania